hello and welcome once again to Android
developer office hours my name is Joe
Malin on your moderator to my right is
Trevor John's beyond him is Jeff Sharkey
and Rado Meyer and producers panel is
Robert Lee and I can't think of anything
else to say at this moment except that
our topic for today is performance more
importantly its efficiency an efficiency
started efficiency okay
great thank you very much
shout out your questions you can get
into the Hangout and call them in or you
can type them in or whatever you want to
do for the moment since we don't have
any of those from the Hangout we're
going to go to moderator and take some
of the questions that have been entered
already the first question is is there a
simple way to get distinct results from
the contacts provider I use the loader
manager degree the cursor loader cursor
is passed to an adapter of an
autocomplete text field but I get dupes
I will try to answer this and if the
person that asked this is online I would
like to know more about exactly what
you're trying to do product my guess is
what you based on what you've said
you're getting duplicates because there
are there are distinct records in the
provider for the same person and that's
the way the provider is supposed to work
you will not the provider is set up so
that different versions of the same
person from different sources are
recorded as distinct records and they're
not the duplicates are not eliminated
what they're what happens is they're a
graduated into a single record that
points to all of these different
versions yeah so for example you could
have you know you're the contact from
Google from your Google contact book as
well as the data that's retrieved from
Google Plus that the user themself
inherited right so depending on how you
access the provider um you could get a
person's record based on their personal
Gmail their work Gmail Google+ etc and
the documentation for contacts provider
that's on developer.android.com explains
to you how to deal with that situation
and get the sort of data that you
maybe looking for and that's probably
why you're getting duplicates if you
were to look at all the information in
the records that are being returned to
you you can see that some of it was
different yeah so I guess this is clip
stay away from the vault contacts table
also the David maple is gonna have
duplicate data as well but I believe the
high-level contacts table should have a
single representation of appropriate of
each person and that that would be a
good starting point if you're trying to
be through the docs there's if you look
in the documentation you'll see some
examples of how to retrieve different
types of information from the provider
and also look at things called entities
and what entities do is come do a sort
of behind the scenes combined of
different pieces of data that help you
do the sorts of things that you might
want to do with the provider but I
definitely suggest you look at the
documentation anything else no I think
that pretty much covered it okay next
question
what are some tips for file manager UI's
I'm currently writing an app that
although it auto saves it save files an
external one should be accessible for
edit to the user the file browsers on
the store are in lists or icons dpi is
also a factor all right so so first
thing don't show the raw file system as
my my recommendation right you know
there's a number of file manager apps
out there you know for example astro and
the review tools for power users but
it's not them although we want for
Android UI is we really want to say okay
here's the documents on your device we
don't really care where they live are
they on internal storage external
storage in some folder all that's
relevant we don't actually want to
expose the underlying you know Linux
file system we just wanna say again here
it's all the docs we could find go ahead
and pick one and open it up if you're
asking whether I should be a list versus
thumbnails versus some sort of icon I
tend to lean a little bit more towards
the idea of either a list or thumbnails
and possibly even allow the user to pick
if you have more screen real estate
thumbnails are really nice but they do
take up more space a good example of if
you're looking at something to model off
of would be Google Docs they do a really
cool Drive excuse me they do a really
awesome ListView for displaying files
and because they don't have a file hug
or a folder hierarchy but by default
they have to go and do that really well
of course you still can't create folders
and they handle that too but that I
guess that's my advice it's really more
of a UI question and without seeing your
app I don't think we can give you
one-size-fits-all recommendations here
but I think that should be some good
general guidance any other comments
yeah one thing to think about when
you're building a file browser like that
you're gonna have the different UI on
phones versus tablets so on a phone you
might end up with that single list view
where the navigate the user navigates
deeper into a file hierarchy you might
be able to present the the tree or the
file system tree on like a left-hand
side pane using something like fragments
on a tablet sized app so it definitely
depends on which size of device you're
targeting you might be able to fit more
or less less details yeah I think
generally you know I just want to
reiterate what what Trevor and Joe have
already said and that is generally
speaking the move has been away from
having sort of hierarchical file
structures for to support your app I
mean it kind of made sense back in sort
of the pre GUI days we had to figure out
a way to be able to put things in a
place you'd be able to find them again
if all you've got is the ability to list
the files in a in a folder and what the
current folder is these days that the
move is very much away from that it's
really more about tagging things making
them more easily searchable and you can
see the way that Google Drive does that
in it your things just sort of sit there
and you can tag them and you can search
for them and same with Gmail which was
sort of the forerunner for that so in
most cases if what you're building is
just a file manager then you know I
think it's it does have some value if
you're figuring out how to put the file
manager into your app to make it easy if
you use this to save files and load
files I'd say that you're probably going
in slightly the wrong direction she'd be
thinking more about how can you make it
easy for people to find the content that
they're looking for without having to
know
a hierarchy in order to do so okay yeah
I would add that the difference is that
if you use some sort of file hierarchy
like old-fashioned directories then
you've just kind of stuck with putting
one thing in one place whereas if you
tagged it or give it some metadata that
you can then search on that for you can
put off put something so to speak in
more than one place at the same time
kind of like the way that labels work in
Gmail I mean they appear sometimes to be
folders but they're really not a message
can be in more than one label it can
have more than one label at the same
time and that's a great benefit to users
yep
and yeah another thing to think about
too we're speeding parkings death here
but when you have nested folders or
nested directories you have to go and
click through all of them and that sort
of a pain on a mobile device it's a lot
easier if you have a list you swipe you
tap you're done and again I layer
touched on this search is incredibly
important to make sure you have that in
there might say it's more important than
tagging if you can only implement one of
these suggestions so it'll be searched
okay okay I don't like all about
creating a category side view which
takes only half the screen when
sufficient real estate is available with
a pager title strip similar to what is
shown in Google Play okay so the
question was can people hear you on the
Hangout yeah okay fine so you've heard
the question I heard the question but
could you repeat it actually sure thing
how do I go about creating a category
side view which it's only half the
screen when sufficient real estate is
available with the pager title strips
similar to what is shown in google play
also yeah I know that in Google Play you
can swipe I'm not sure what the side
view is that we're trying to pull it up
here so we have an example so you go to
the top level go into one of the
yes I gotta go into Ola yeah I think
it'll even work in portrait as well
oh cool all right in one of the app so
like app so many times yeah we need to
hook up our hdmi tablet here so we can
actually show you this okay so let me
yeah let me just demonstrate turn it
around
yeah hold up to the camera screen I'm
gonna declare when I pull when it stops
halfway across then pull it back
it's exactly a half way so that's I
presume that that's the functionality
that they are looking for excellent
getting head knots alright that's a good
question how would you do that so I
would guess that this isn't this isn't
using a viewpager
oh well at least it's a modified version
of you pager
yeah I don't think my knowledge there's
no way by default to ask for your Pedro
do that for you there's another question
abut further down on the question q2
which touches on the others which is
asking like for example Google+ when you
tap the home button you have a
navigation panel that slides out from
the left and right now there's nothing
in the support library or otherwise else
when the framework that really makes it
easy to do and our recommendation
actually right now is really it's an
awesome model I love it
but it's not something were actually
actively recommending the people because
there's been so much flux with these
widgets everybody's done it a little bit
differently so there's not really a
single recommended approach as far as
our UI guidelines are concerned so if
you really do want to implement it right
now you're sort of on your own over time
once we actually figure out what the you
know the right way this should look
should be will probably we'll add it
somewhere a support library most likely
but that's a ways off and that's
assuming that we actually said we liked
it right this always possible will
change our minds later on so yeah pretty
much you're on your own unfortunately
and there's really and from the
technical perspective if you want a good
place to start I'd start with viewpager
and start modifying that but it's not
going to be as simple as just having a
at property so it looks so if we try and
think it through so it looks like what
it's doing is it's a because all of the
other interaction works exactly the same
as view pager so if you started with
that and it looks like all
doing a saying if if you're at n plus
one well I guess at one then this is you
know limit the size of the of the
fragment for the zeroth fragment right
that would seem to be a place to start
so have a look at the viewpager and what
you want to do is modify the behavior if
the first fragment is visible so that it
doesn't fully extend to the full width
of the of the screen I think we have any
sample code sir nope I'm not a weapon
either yeah the person that hang out
says they looked into that using a view
flipper in combination with animations
but they cannot figure out how to limit
the size yeah never another beautiful
bird great a suggestion
they tried what you it so they tried
what I suggested to the viewpager and
they're gonna find out how to limit the
size yeah I think that's going to be the
struggle because the the way that the
viewpager is designed is to effectively
just do the animations between to set
frames and so instead of having those
two fragments on screen I mean the other
possibility that you may want to try is
to have the zeroth fragment contain so
that what you're actually looking at on
that view pager isn't actually the last
fragment being half-width it's just that
the last fragment looks like the
previous fragment and the first fragment
joined together if that makes sense so I
don't know how you would do the
animation but maybe once you get halfway
across and then it switches it oh no
it's getting a little bit Airy even in
my own mind but yeah we we'd be
interested to see how you get on but I
don't think that there's an easy
solution for that at this point
unfortunately like Trevor says there's
the best chance in terms of getting
something relatively straightforward is
to wait and see if we or anyone else
creates a standardized widget to do
something similar to what do you pass on
YouTube did
okay we've got another question on the
Hangout all right I am looking for tools
or methods that will help me test my app
in extreme conditions for example low
memory low disk space high CPU usage and
in parentheses that is done by another
process okay first up here extreme
conditions like are you gonna go and try
and like drop it in a volcano or watch
it into space take it over to Antarctica
space has been done by the way we
actually have launched Android phones
into space but I am not aware of
anything on its volcanoes but seriously
though you know a good volcano nearby so
yeah some of the things like slow
Network in particular their support for
in the emulator now low disk space I'm
not aware of any really good automated
ways to go and test that other than
writing a script that goes and dumps a
bunch of files onto your SD card I know
there are some third-party companies
that make some test suites that you go
and test some things like you know what
happens when the battery gets low so off
the top of my head I believe testdroid
is one of the ones that can do some of
this stuff I don't think it can do
everything on your list but it's worth
looking into that's by a company called
bit bar and so that they offer as a
subscription service where you upload
your apk to their servers and they run a
series of tests on devices you've
supplied to them sorry on devices
they've supplied for you yeah you'd have
to mail them any devices and that's
probably your best but if you're looking
to try and do a lot of this sort of
trying to go and automate a bunch of it
yourself using things like ADB to go and
actually ADB only gets you so far even
like if you're trying to test their
battery you'd have to hook up some
hardware and you know start modifying
the voltage that's a tough one so really
really no easy way there other than what
the emulator already provides and it
does supply some of it so definitely
look at that first one of the tool that
can potentially be really powerful is
the monkey which will which generates a
bunch of random events I so touches on
the screen keyboard event inputs and
it'll push them push your app in all
different directions and we use that a
lot on the team to help
cover bugs and all verbs across the
platform so to generate a lot of that
noise I mean it'll uncover race
conditions a lot of times I in code so
the monkey tool is great you can find
that it's just a using a to be on the
command line similarly I think that if
you're trying to simulate these sort of
extreme conditions based on what other
apps are doing the easiest solution in a
lot of cases is going to be to create
your own version of those other apps and
the extreme conditions are going to be
when other apps are misbehaving so you
get to have fun and create an app which
is really poorly behaved it does
everything that we tell you not to do it
which chews up memory and causes other
apps to effectively swap out and get
killed yeah I think we actually I think
was it Dan hack born would actually
something very similar to that thrown in
to analyse for a while my own our own
builds had a very very badly misbehaving
app installed on them for a bit to go
and try and test what happens when when
apps misbehave thankfully that doesn't
ship but yeah I think that's probably a
good approach is you know just write
your really bad app and that's you know
gonna go and cover a list from the
performance side of things what happens
when things go wrong it's usually the
easiest way to do it you can you can do
a lot through simulating things but
ultimately it's gonna be you know how
does my app behave when another app is
using all my bandwidth using all my
processor using all my storage is to
build that other app and it gives you
the control as well because then you can
decide how far you want it to go so at
what point does my app stop being
unresponsive and what steps should I
take to try and help the system Oh any
other comments nope okay thank you
gentlemen
now let's move on oops I think I skipped
one here I have a fragment which uses a
loader it implements the loader
callbacks I have set retain instance
true for the fragment so that is not
destroy across orientation changes
however the loader it creates in the
oncreate loader gets reset why
that's a good question yeah actually I
have never seen this behavior before so
I'm not sure what the answer is off the
top of my head this also I think was
when a later question to come into the
Q's I think a chance to research it
beforehand yeah I actually do not know
the answer to this yeah our usual advice
if you can go ahead and post a question
on Stack Overflow we try and take a look
at anything that we can't answer after
the show and get an answer for you so
just go ahead and drop a a comment on
the strong the the G+ post pointing to a
stack overflow question and we'll try
and get some more detail for you after
the show this one in particular said
retain incident State on fragments is
awesome but generally it's designed to
work specifically for fragments which
don't have a UI which is a perfectly
good place to put a loader so one of the
things that I've mentioned is of a word
of caution is that if you are using that
on a fragrant with UI that may be
causing the problem so I need to look
into more detail because this is
something just vaguely tingling in the
back of my mind but generally speaking
the server taneous and state property is
designed for you eyeless fragments yeah
you know that question on the Hangout
alright I have a performance question
related of databases what are the
overhead implications with sequel light
and increasing the number of tables hmm
that's a good question I'd say yeah
adding more tables properly it's not
going to hurt you too much what is going
to hurt you is joins and at some point
just having so many records that takes a
while day to write through all of them
setting indexes wisely is definitely
going to help indexes do increase the
cost when you perform a light and it's a
trade off next gene you get faster read
times I'd say yeah that's pretty much
really see most of your performance is
20 joins and trying to iterate through a
lot of records or searching on fields
that don't have an index that sort of
thing
adding more adding more tables should be
fine so performance impact minimal any
other comments all right let's move on
in the past I've used an intense service
to load data from a breast-- web service
but I saw that in the new Google i/o app
that async loaders are used extensively
is loader currently the recommended way
to low remote data when should intense
service be used okay so I think this
one's a bit of confusion about the way
the Google i/o app works so using an
async loader to go and pull data from a
web service doesn't actually sound a
very good idea to me and we actually
don't do that in the Google i/o app what
we do do is we have a background service
in conjunction with a sync adapter which
goes and fetches the data from the web
service stores is in a local database
and then that loader is used to go and
fetch the data out of the local database
and that's the model we're using it's
nice because we don't have to worry
about trying to fetch data well the apps
running everything's already cached
locally and in the background we
actually can send a GCM message to the
phone ask informing if the schedules
changed and then it can go and update or
update the conference schedule in the
background so that way every time you
open the app you have to wait for a
couple minutes well that's just the
latest schedule data you know you always
have the latest data right on your phone
they're already stashed so as far as the
other half of the question which is
should or when shouldn't end service be
used and I think in that case say it
really quickly it's a matter of
convenience what's easier for you in 10
service system than I when there's a
service were still running as a service
it's justa nearly intense services more
my family look quickly because I've
actually never used that one myself but
I think that's more for one-off jobs you
specify a bunch of the you specify your
request inside of an attempt or as in
this case since we're always going and
doing the same thing over and over again
we're always fetching these you know
these
schedule changes there's really you know
I think it looks better as just a
self-contained background service they
don't if you have any comments on when
intent service is a better choice
yeah actually mean we enjoyed I've
actually been out talking about this a
little bit over the last couple of weeks
I think if you're looking specifically
between intent service and async task I
think that's generally the sort of
question people have is often will come
across the async task class first and
see it is a really convenient way of
being able to do background stuff you
want to get off the UI thread to work in
Android and it's great and it does all
of the marshaling to the UI thread for
you which is really really handy but
that's kind of a clue as to when it's
most appropriate as well so there is
some overhead associated with it
and what it's really designed for is
doing something within your activity
which is going to have a direct impact
on your UI so if it's something which is
allowed to get destroyed as soon as your
activity gets closed because remember of
course that your async tasks within an
activity as soon as you rotate the
device they're all going to get killed
so it's really stuff which should not be
long-lived it's just too time consuming
to do on the UI thread in sensors is
just a really neat way of being able to
encapsulate one of the most common
service implementations implementation
patterns so service is basically
designed there for anything within your
app which needs to live longer than the
average lifespan of a particular
activity instance so anything which
needs to live across multiple activities
anything which should stay continued to
be active when you're rotating the
screen all that sort of stuff should
live in a service so anything which
you're downloading which is more than
you know anything non-trivial which of
downloading probably wants to be in a
service and the intent service is really
handy because it creates this queue for
you so it'll just basically create a
serial queue where you keep sending it
commands to do and it will just keep
going through them until all the tasks
have been done and then neatly kill the
service for you so if you're doing
things like intermittent download so as
as Trevor says anything which is going
to be on a regular schedule anything
which has to
happen you know on an ongoing basis
she'd probably lose you know you
something like a sync adapter but if
you're just going to be downloading
things when a user click something so
you don't really know when it's going to
happen then intent so this is perfect
because you just send it the send it the
thing say oh I want you to download this
you will download it when it's finished
it updates your content provider and
then your UI automatically gets updated
via its loader when the content provider
associated with it has been updated so
it just helps to create that nice sort
of you know pattern for you and often
that's kind of the way it works as well
as like you intuitively like you when
you first get started with something you
have an activity you have your UI so
there's a temptation to just do
everything within that class and it's
kind of the trick behind Android is that
you're your sort of main form he's
actually made up of your activity plus
the services that support a plus but
potentially a content provider as well
so you really need to think of all of
those modules and how they fit together
in order to create something that works
in the best one thank you good answer
make all you need to take it beverage to
voice in my mouth any other comments so
then one of their value of intent
service is really I if you're in your UI
and you want to persist something if you
really want to make sure that it gets
saved
that's what intent service is there for
because even if the user hits the HOME
key or gets an incoming phone call um if
you've kicked that off in an async task
there's the potential that your process
gets killed and that data may not be
saved so if the data is important send
it off to that intent service it's
something that's important to persist
yeah that's a very good point I would
add that it's really great for being
able to go send off some work to be done
allowing the user then to go off and do
any other tasks that may come up so that
if a phone call comes in or the user
wants to go off and do some work and
wait for this thing to finish they can
go do that and then get
notification or some other indication on
when the work is done and then go back
to the activity okay let's move another
live question shoot is there a way to
use a different class loader at
development time not necessary for
production for services
it looks like it's possible to do this
for activities using instrumentations a
new activity method but I'd like to do
this for all parts of an app a different
class order okay the only thing that
instrumentation does really in terms of
loading classes is that it allows you a
little bit of extra control or injection
into activities and there's
instrumentation available for services
and for content providers as well as for
activities that's the only answer that I
can give myself so that I'd be curious
to see what the use case is to know what
the answer would be yeah I mean I know
it definitely is possible to specify a
different class loader within your
activity when you're circling and firing
off other things like creating a new
service creating other activities I
think you have limited control there but
I know that definitely is a way to go
and control things once your activity
has gotten started so unfortunately it's
not a very common task so I can't
remember the way to do it off the top of
my head but I know it definitely can be
done for example I know there was some
talk a while back of trying to use this
as an investigation mechanism and in
classes and do all sorts of other fun
things like that again not something I
do you recommend most developers try and
concern themselves with is lots of
pitfalls lie-down that where I would but
definitely as possible right yeah that's
that's the question
oh the activity itself I don't think
that's possible I think it's a very the
best you can use load classes within the
activity
because activity startup ISM it is not
something that you can control like by
the time you have control your activity
has already been loaded well except
where you get a chance will they need
that one before you activities actually
created and it will get it maybe
slightly before location instance maybe
it's worth the try but don't think any
of us have ever attempted to do that no
it's it like I said lots of lots of
dangers when you start messing with the
class loader it's usually something I
recommend people stay away from also
it's a little odd we've been doing a lot
of questions today that are text only
you guys are welcome to go and hop on
video chat or audio just like Robert our
producer no and till make sure that you
get patched in live to us and we can
actually talk to your face-to-face but
well what we are more than happy to
answer text questions to if you don't
have a camera okay we'll move along to
the next question in moderator how to
create the drop-down slide in navigation
from action home up button it is you is
it as convoluted as all my Google
results indicate or is there a simple
way to do it Google Plus YouTube and
Spotify incorporate this feature so I
think we already answered this one
earlier but just to reiterate yes it is
as concluded as all your Google results
indicate and on that note also we don't
recommend really pursuing this until we
have a recommendation as part of our our
design guide or the very least that
people start coming up with some
libraries to do it there's really
nothing out there that makes it easy yet
that said if you've actually like to go
and write you know like the first
library to implement this I'm sure
there's a lots of developers I would
thank you but right now it's not
something we can really recommend people
do unless they're really adventurous as
well if anyone does decide to take
Trevor up on that on that challenge that
so far the consensus so each of these
different different implementations you
mentioned are slightly different in the
way that they work and that's part of
what Trevor is talking about is that
there isn't a real consensus based on
the style guide us to the right way that
said the the consensus seems to be
heading towards the YouTube model being
sort of the the right way of doing that
so if you do want to implement something
similar look at the way the YouTube app
has implemented it and head in that
direction but for now it's definitely
not for beginners I think it's gonna be
a little tricky to do ok has a live
video question go for it yeah fire away
vodka layup where we have an ad with a
button next to it to like launched an
in-app purchase but every time we don't
give that view the full width of the
layout it freaks out and says that it
can't display the ad but even if we
create a VM that has a you know really
tiny screen that is equivalent to what
space it has it will display the ad as
long as we give it you know like match
parent or fill parent and so we're
trying to figure out how we can solve
this right now what we were thinking
about is making a fragment that it was
allowed to take the full width up but
I'd like to not complicate the layouts
too much if possible
okay so repeat this and repeat this you
you've done an ad that you want to
display with a button next to it to do
something like in that purchasing
correct okay and every time you try to
set that up on it complains because it
says you don't have enough room to
display the ad correct interesting so
the ads are coming from a good party
provider like AdMob or something like
that yes
okay interesting so this is only going
to be an issue on certain size displays
right so if it's if it's a a phone where
the the AdMob banner is specified to be
the right size to fit basically the full
width of the phone then then you're
gonna have that issue when you try to
put something next to it is that it's
alright yeah except for if we create a
like a virtual machine that has a width
in pixels of what what they you know the
vo would be expanded into as long as we
don't put the button here works fine so
we know that that amount of real estate
is sufficient to display the ad that's
yeah that's interesting well one we
think about that one thing which I would
mention is that you need to be really
careful when you're trying to create
something like what you're describing so
one of the requirements we have you know
I think it's out developer content
policy is that you shouldn't be putting
ads anywhere where a user may
accidentally click them and so putting
ads right next to a button which you
want people to press for any reason may
actually be in violation of that because
it would be very easy to get confused
and accidentally hit the ad instead of a
button yes they're called fickle I can't
remember calling me I can have a look
how the Pandora app works like I said
I'm not we do the ads behind the
interface buttons
that doesn't sound awesome um yeah so I
can't comment on other apps and and what
they may or may not be doing right it's
just something which has come up at
least once before with a developer I was
working with you you ran into some
problems on on that basis so I'd be I'd
be cautious you you basically want to
have any of your in
active elements as far away from your
ads as possible to avoid running into
those kinds of issues okay because I see
Keys mentioned something about not being
a place ads buttons close to the ads so
is that possibly the API is seeing that
in causing a problem or that's actually
possible I haven't considered that but
it is possible that the actual AdMob API
is looking and seeing oh you've got a
button right next to the ad that's you
know not kosher
so yeah in it does seem a little strange
I'd be a little bit surprised if it was
smart enough to do that on your behalf
but just from a from UX perspective if
nothing else I think it's really not
best practice to have your interactive
elements is that close to your banner
ads right okay so regarding an app
purchase button then would that be
something like in the overflow of the
action bar that what you're buying right
it depends on the nature of they not
purchase okay so it's an update for your
app that adds additional for you all
right so yeah the overflow menu is
certainly one option the downside there
is discoverability right people do the
idea behind that workflow menu is you
never see it unless you really want to
go looking through it a better idea is
just to go and put a just so you know
when users get to the part of the app
where they try and get to the premium
features is where you could start
promoting the upgrade so have the UI
controls available and then when you
click on them you could pop up a dialog
saying this is reserved for a pool
version or you could have an entirely
separate screen with all the controls to
say a bold and say you know click here
to upgrade I'd yeah I probably a better
idea just to go and display the dialog
as soon as they click on click on the
button that takes you to that part of
your app now I still would have a an
option in the overflow menu to go and
apply the upgrade for people who know
they really want to get to it to keep
them having to dig but you definitely
look at other opportunities for
upselling right trying to figure out you
know how users will know that there's
actually additional value that is
something they want to buy yep
thank you question anybody else all
right we'll move on to the next question
a moderator is that okay yeah so the
producer says okay I'm living several
images from disk at basically the same
time using a background thread of course
however loading so many images in a
matter of milliseconds will cause GC for
alloc causing noticeable Jing anything
they can do about that oh it sounds like
couple famous question Jeff John take a
shot at this sure so it's something to
realize is even in that background
thread if you're making that allocation
you're allocating those bitmaps if you
do end up having to do this GC for alloc
it'll it could potentially end up
blocking in the main thread of your
application that's running the the UI
the animation um if that main thread is
also trying to allocate things so really
what you're looking to do here is you
want to really optimize and minimize the
number of allocations you're doing on
that main thread because where you might
find in this case is there's one small
little allocation that's being exposed
to this pause from the background thread
if you're able to get the UI animation
done with zero allocations if you're get
it all the way down to zero um you
probably wouldn't see that pause that
you're describing yeah
also I'll add that I did a code lab at
Google i/o that did something very
similar to the behavior you're
describing and specifically we I created
a grid view that loads a bunch of really
high resolution images over and over
again and we sort of walk people through
going and finding all the the hotspots
in the code all the things that would
cause a garbage collection cause you're
just general jank everything that was
bad and we'd go and take get rid of them
one after the other and I think that you
can get a link to it from the Google i/o
website if not it is on my own website T
John's net slash il 2012 I have all the
code up there yeah important things make
sure you know of course for performance
reasons you're gonna want to load your
your images in the background thread use
async task or something similar also
make sure that you're reusing all of
your you know your ListView element your
year yeah little is it item use I think
the word
make sure you will use those they do get
recycled and just make sure that you
reuse object whenever possible
on that note make sure that your
recycling bitmaps to write all the usual
things for whenever you're dealing with
with bitmaps apply there because there
they do take up a lot of memory and it's
very easy to mess up and cause calls
objects we created when they don't need
to be and we've added a lot of hooks
there especially like I said that you
can recycle bitmaps and you know hang on
to things that way actually
recycling a bitmap actually gets rid of
it right Turner what the right way to do
it is by the view and what the right way
to handle bitmaps like we use the the
address space there for it I'm trying to
remember it I because there is like a
release method or a recycle right but I
don't think that's what recycling
actually completely gets rid of it but
there is a method where you can pass it
in an existing instance into a bitmap
options as part of the inflate and
that's one of the that's the mechanism
that you're describing that would allow
you to recycle those existing
allocations right via the the biggest
takeaway though is avoid allocations
inside of your drawing on your own draws
because that's what's it's probably
exposing in this case onto that jank yep
and you can take a look in DDMS there is
an allocation track that will show you
all of your memories going and that
should give you a pretty strong clue as
to what's causing all these GC events
all right I actually have a question
from someone on the on the invite Simon
Markey who wants to know what is the
best choice to play a list of music
files for an app and sometimes
interrupts them to play in effect sound
and he's listed a couple of ideas and
and also what is the you know is there a
best practice to probably handle the
sound like when the screen is off and so
on and so forth so I'm going to jump in
and answer that as well so yes sound
pool is the API that you want to look
for to
best handled that sort of thing so you
know a variety of different sound
effects and music within within a game
sound Paul is definitely a friend and
the media player API should you need it
but I think you should actually be able
to handle most things within sample by
itself in terms of the best way to
handle sound playing our good friends
from the Friday review in Lewis and Dan
Galpin actually covered this in some
detail at their Google i/o talk ten
things all game developers should know
so check that out and that will give you
some great advice particularly how to
handle things like music playback during
the lockscreen and when the screens off
and those sorts of things
great answer thank you thank you very
much next question from moderator in the
developers console for one app the
content rating has the everyone rating
disabled and next to it it says this
rating option has been disabled by the
Google Play team what could have caused
this well the answer is actually like
that in front of your face it was
manually set by a member of the Google
Play team so they we do periodically
review apps and if we notice that an app
has an incorrect lating its lated lower
than it should be we'll go and make a
manual adjustment and that's what you're
seeing there so basically they're saying
your app contains some sort of content
that it makes it unsuitable for everyone
and yeah in my experience the most
common cause for that is typically if
you're using some sort of dual
requesting file location in your app as
a permission then there is a minimum
level maturity level which it has to be
I think it's not the lowest possibly the
next up from that at least so that tends
to be the most common case it can also
be if there is you know if your apps
being flagged and the Play team are
looking through to it to make sure that
it's compliant with our content policies
and so on and they do it manually for
those reasons as well but location I
think is typically the most common
case for this sort of thing that's good
to know
okay great uh next question from
moderator when using an MHL adapter to
get HDMI out some apps like YouTube show
different views on the device display
and the HDMI output how's that done I
could not find any API for this is it
Hardware dependent so I did some digging
into this and the answer is there isn't
really an API this is something that's
done by the system
whenever at least the the Google
Experience devices detect a video
surface they'll modify the HDMI output
to go and display the contents of only
that video surface so it's not something
that YouTube is explicitly doing it's
something the system is taken care of
automatically now that said this
behavior is not guaranteed for all
devices
it's a vendor specific implementation
detail so other devices might use to
handle HDMI differently but you know to
answer your question though if you want
to go and display some custom content on
the other display there's not really a
way to do it right now it's just limited
to videos okay thank you I have two
questions from the from the live invite
one is by gosh that's a name which is
gonna be hard for me to jazz leg bunker
who would like to know the name of the
guy in the Hat oh hey my name is Trevor
John's oh I'm actually on here almost
every week usually without a hat but
yeah I'm I'm on the same team as Joe and
Ray they were all members of the Android
developer relations team so yeah we are
we we are sort of trying to implement
possibly having a mandatory hat wearing
person in each of our sessions that's
usually Dan Galpin on Friday but seeing
as Dan doesn't sit in on these sessions
we thought we'd see that I Trevor can
support a hat with the style to which
we've become accustomed yeah the next
question is from Nicholas Johnson and
he's attempting to develop a rich text
component with buttons the typical
rich text editing and he goes on to say
that spans make really difficult to work
with the whole thing is kind of a pain
particularly when you get to things like
Texas election so my my suggestion here
I'll be interested to see if you guys
agree but uh attempting to develop a
rich text editing component within
Android is not going to be simple you're
effectively gonna have to recreate the
edit text component from scratch because
as soon as you're trying to do things
like change colors mid line add italics
and bold and so on and so forth to
arbitrary text within a full control
then you really need to also take care
of how that layout is going to work so
you're effectively going to end up
having to recreate the edit text
component from scratch into something
which within a fairly short amount of
time is going to look a lot like a web
browser which is in fact how a lot of
teams have have implemented this sort of
thing so where they do have the need for
rich text editing rather than being
something a variation of the edit text
it's actually a webview within within
the app so that I don't know my gut
feeling is that that's kind of gonna be
the way to go if you want to have
something like anything beyond sort of
really simple markup how do you guys
feel yeah I think that that pretty much
covers it rich text is definitely that's
very difficult to implement and webview
covers most of it already it covers more
than you probably want so because you're
looking for expansion and honestly most
of the time when people are doing rich
text anyway they're gonna go and want to
convert it to HTML so using a webview
takes care of that for you as well okay
thank you
next question from moderator I've
noticed that some apps that use action
bar tabs for navigation will have the
tabs replaced with the drop-down list
one switch to landscape well there isn't
enough room for tabs is there a way to
force it to do that landscape tags are
ugly
okay I think the simple answer for me is
to try and use an action bar where
possible because that's gonna already
have that sort of toggle between you
know a navigation in so it's gonna be a
drop down navigation in portrait mode
and sort of in action bar tabs
potentially in in landscape mode so you
can sort of do that variation yourself
it doesn't necessarily help you for if
you want to have apps which work prior
to honeycomb mind you but you can
certainly try and use that same sort of
model in general my feeling is that your
your tab host control isn't great but I
mean this is talking about action bar
tabs in general so yeah okay so it's
specific to action bar tab so that would
be my suggestion is to just switch
between them using the the the spinner
in portrait and there and the tabs in in
landscape versa all right thank you very
much next question got a hangout
question shoot a club I created a test
database and expert exported the strings
to insert test data looping through a
string array and we're all executing
each command to populate the database
put it I couldn't use begin to
transaction because I was already in one
any advice for creating a test database
on a device so you were already in a
transaction so just to I I don't know if
they're running this so it's an Android
program it's an Android app and they're
attempting to build a pre-populated
database is that that's what it sounds
like um so that you should be able to
create everything inside of a single
transaction on your own I'm not sure
with the exact I it shouldn't be
creating a transaction on your behalf
you should be able to begin and manage
your own but yeah with without any more
detail the the other thing he was
mentioning is that it's designed to be
generated once so he's pre generating a
sequel like database to then ship we're
getting some clear
okay it was in the on Crete in the open
helper okay you should be able to i/o so
if it's in the oncreate you yeah you're
right you may already be in a
transaction at that point on so if
you're looking to test performance it
should be as as good as it's going to
get on the one of the thing to
potentially look at is when you're doing
that initial database setup I mean
you're inserting a lot of data in a bulk
way you may look at I creating your
indexes after you've inserted all of the
data if you create the indexes and then
do a whole bunch of inserts on the
database is going to may try updating
those indexes as you're inserting all of
your data but if you insert the data
first and then create the indexes you
may end up with less work on the
database engine side of things so it may
be faster okay any response from them he
said thanks okay well I don't got any
more questions yeah just holler out
otherwise we'll move on to the next
question and moderator
um I have to load an image with certain
restrictions for example I have an 8
megapixel picture that I want to send a
crop as a square rotate and maybe scale
it what's the most efficient way to do
this without creating new bitmaps and
recycling the old one all right that's
so that's actually a pretty good
question yeah Jeff you don't have an
answer off the top of your head for that
um so I think it depends on your zoom
mean if the user can zoom in on the the
photo and while they're actually working
on it because there are some eyes so the
8 megapixel that's a lot of data behind
the scenes so there's a handful of
bitmapfactory the bitmap options you can
actually request to have it down sampled
so you can request it to maybe only load
every other pixel so instead of a an 8
megapixel photo now you're working with
a 4 megapixel so there's some options
there that you can load a lower
resolution version of the photo for the
user to edit it may not be the full
quality that they're expecting on the VB
lower resolution once you've decided the
mutation operations that the user wants
to perform once they've chosen like the
exact rotation you can go back and
perform a high-quality pass
of those operations on the full
resolution photo so that may allow you
to make your UI nice and fast you're
maybe rotating and manipulating
something lower quality but then
applying it as a planet later against
the full resolution image that seems
like it will be a fairly good approach
for what they're describing here because
it's it's fairly coarse grained stuff so
sent to crops where it rotate so it
sounds like they just basically want to
be able to load up any picture and in
the same way that you choose like a
profile pic or something in a social
network you just needed to be square so
you just pick it I think in that
instance particularly on an Android app
you know even if you are zooming in as
long as it's sort of good enough to see
what the what the edges are you can do
that and then do like a live preview of
the crop data at a higher res maybe yeah
and yeah bitmap factory has methods to
do most of that stuff the only one I'm
not clear about is rotation I'm not sure
if you can have it rotate for you if
that's the case you might even want to
consider sub-classing but not factory
and adding rotation in there so that way
all these operations are performed as
you're loading the bitmap and that that
would help reduce than that yeah if you
can do before you create your bitmap
then you only have to click one bitmap
yeah the benefit of using those those
options is that skia down deep in the
native code is the one that's doing this
down sampling so your your application
doesn't have to allocate 8 megapixels
worth of data to store the data all
right to store the image when it's
inflated I'm so it's doing it in a very
optimized way under the hood ok thank
you
next question from moderator could you
consider maintaining the Android and
support library artifacts officially in
maven central whoever does it now can be
a bit slow and it is a pain in the ass
one of a better word so yeah future cost
notice we've always had a bit of
reluctance to go and support any build
systems aside from eclipse just because
that's what we decided that we wanted to
go and spend our time supporting and
we've always left everything else to the
community to do I'll definitely pass
that along to the build team and let the
digital team rather and let them know
there's a feature request for that that
being said I'm pretty sure they've heard
it before it's not the first time I've
seen this come up but you know most
likely
it's gonna be a bit of a tough sell
because we have we have chosen to go and
focus most of our efforts on the clips
but again I'll make sure they get that
feedback related to that as well I mean
we we sit right next to the tools team
so if you guys have like questions or
requests or something like that you'd
like to see us do a hangout or something
like this specifically so you guys can
talk to them let us know and we will
schedule something up so yeah that is a
resource available we're not part of
that team so we aren't necessarily but
yeah the best position to answer those
sorts of questions all right we're
getting towards the end so let's move on
through as quickly as we can did the
Nexus S have it's offline voice
dictation and hot work detection
disabled in 4.1.1 due to inadequate
audio hardware if so what are your
guidelines for testing if device is for
running for that one to meet the
baseline for using the relevant new
multimedia ap is I don't think anybody
knows the answer to that given that none
of us work on the voiced V for the voice
team so this is probably a question
better suited for another office hours
we might have somebody from the worst
team on but like now we have no expert
to can actually give you a definitive
answer there yeah go for it
it's about location updates in a service
is it better battery wise to sample
updates from network or passive
providers on an interval or register on
start a listener or pending intent and
depend on the request updates parameters
for a min time and man distance okay so
let me see if I understand this so the
question is are they better off polling
so basically getting a lot get
last-known location or using a we're
basically asking for location-based
updates at a minimum time and distance
is that the gist yeah so when I remember
guest la get last position is literally
returning the last known position which
is not gonna be where the user is that
necessarily at that given moment so that
is one issue you have to deal with
but I would say Jen I mean in terms of
terms of efficiency hmm so in terms of
efficiency I would almost never
recommend a poling approach they just it
as soon as you're polling for anything
then you'll be creating a minimum amount
of time where the device is going to be
on responding to whatever it is that
you're doing at that wake up so if you
can have anything which is more
on-demand that tends to be a better
solution so I I would yeah I would
definitely go with actually creating a
location listener particularly for
passive provider that way if there are
no apps requesting location updates then
your app will never get triggered so it
will go to sleep and so this is really
important when the device is on standby
so if you are doing a polling solution
then you're still going to wake the
device and you're still going to check
to see when what that last location
update was even if it hasn't changed for
an hour whereas you actually got a
listener registered it's no less
efficient than polling in terms of the
work it's doing and you had the
advantage of being on demand so that you
know it's only gonna happen as
frequently as any other app is actually
making those location requests okay
thank you um this is an interesting one
can you take another look at my question
from last week ran out of time at the
end question is how to iterate through
fragments in a tabbed view pager to tell
each fragment the paint data which has
been updated by a loader in the main
activity I might be hearing that
question last week following their
production I don't I don't think we had
a great answer then and I'm not sure
that there really is one yeah I I still
my question is why are you trying to do
this given that you're only gonna have
one one page on your view pager visible
and trying to ask anything else to
update else in the background it's just
a waste of CPU most of the most UI
events don't occur for objects which are
which are off screen now that being said
you know the question area that the
answer here is yeah basically your
typical solution for communicating with
five minutes I don't think if you I
don't think viewpager really has
anything to do with it it's really a
matter of just going and sending a
method
to all of your five banks so it'll
register some sort of callback method so
that your your activity can just go and
and deliver a message to all the known
fragments when these events happen and
let them know that they have stale data
which needs to be refreshed at some
point which is appropriate and that's
kind of so data set observer is one way
that list views for example connect up
to cursors so when you assign a cursor
to a cursor loader and it's bound to a
list view that that list view may be
often one of those other fragments on
but the data set observer is the
mechanism by which it knows I need to
invalidate and repaint my content so a
strategy like that there's data side
observer and data side observable
there's me there's me be good at
strategy okay oh we got don't hang out
question in two more minutes all right
but hang out question last one here this
person has quite a big database of
assets and dumps it into an SD card is
there a way to access this database
directly to assets so I don't have to
duplicate it since it's like six
megabytes does that make sense yes I
think what he wants to do here is
basically similar to the question which
one of the earlier question is had which
is I want a pre-populated database but I
don't you know I don't want to download
it you know piecemeal I just want to be
able to dump it on an SD card possibly
as part of the installation process or
as a one-off and right now you would
have to do all the usual ways that you
would then have to open that database
move everything into an SQLite database
and have the content provider on top of
that to do most operations so I think
the question here is is there a way you
can just point to that database and say
this is my database treated the same way
you would an SQLite database that you
had opened so I'm not sure I'm not sure
that I have an answer I think if it is
an SQLite database then you probably can
if it's not and I'm not sure that that's
I think do you guys have any so single
life databases I think you can open
based on an explicit file system path we
could tell it opens file but what thing
one thing to note is that I if it's
living out on the SD card on anyone
could come along open it right a bowl
and write all any sort of data in there
which then your app is gonna go consume
so anything on the SD card is is
publicly available for other apps to
write into the other thing is if you're
using it for persistence just be aware
that sometimes that you know the SD card
it can disappear on but it may also not
be on the SD card can be of varying
quality because they're using a
different file system that's maybe not
as resilient if you're using the
internal file system on the device and
maybe it's like yaps or ext4 it's a lot
more resilient to like changes if the
user pulls the battery out of their
device yeah I think that I really just
want to emphasize that that first point
which is that it's trivially easy for
your SD card to be or your shared shared
space to be unmounted and if someone
plugs it into their computer boom your
database disappears if they unclick
their SD card boom your database is gone
and so that adds a certain amount of mmm
how can I say it doesn't do bad things
it doesn't do good things into your app
so suddenly you have to keep in mind the
fact that your database may just
disappear mid transaction and figure out
how you're gonna recover from that and
as well as Jeff said it can change so it
can be mounted to a computer then have
all of its data changed and then plug
back in and you need to figure out what
you're gonna do with that now so it's
generally not generally not great
practice to go that way granted if
you've got a very large database it
seems like a reasonable alternative but
you may actually want to consider
storing and keeping most of that on a
server and just downloading effectively
enough data to have cached a reasonable
amount of data to be able to respond to
when you're offline rather than storing
the entire thing on
on the phone depending on your usage
mama may know that may not work okay
uh-huh
so I think with us that's it for time I
think we have run off the end of the
clock so once again thank you everybody
for stopping in and we will see you next
week
thanks everyone